he's my point that what we did here
despite being quite straightforward it
does require a bit of black magic
doesn't it you've got it you've got to
see it and before you see it it's what
do I do
where do I go right now therefore that's
that's why we introduced this idea okay
and to sort of you might segue into this
I want you to look at these now tell me
my story skills good enough that you can
recognize that they are yes does anyone
know no pressure physics did it how do
you guys work and why do we sometimes
have small gears and sometimes we have
big gears
why do we sometimes have one over the
other and you're nervous
yes and again okay what tell me about
speed what what's the difference between
took about one over the other and it's
advantage why in a case where you want
something small to turn why mic should
put something big there instead this
spins faster so maybe if you want
something to spin faster
not only does it spin faster but doesn't
require as much now I'm gonna make sure
I use the right word because I know
effort don't compare that can be
confusing so I'm just thinking turns off
if I had like a handle on this thing
right but I had to move around around on
this handle would be relatively easy to
turn versus this okay but it's it's much
easier to turn what's the trade-off
what's the disadvantage to me I've got
to all the internal energy like is it
the same energy I'm not sure it's not
enough to I'm clean on the turns but at
least in terms of my thinking this is
easier for me and move but I've got to
move it right I think of how far my arms
have to go in order to do like well in
order to do one revolution
okay versus he they're just going around
a little bit but it's much harder to
turn okay it's the same principle on
which spanners work if you've got like a
this is what I was starting to do
beforehand
I couldn't reverse panel if I had one of
these right it's like a you know it's
that big okay and you go ahead with your
fingers you're like you're gonna break
your fingers off before you actually get
anywhere right but you get a spanner on
it and it's very easy to do now this
question the way you did it right I
liken it to a small gear okay look it's
not very complicated
it's very sorry ya know break open it
it's very quick like very few lines of
working it doesn't take very far to get
there ah but if you don't see it if you
know the mental ability to sort of like
walk out what's the thing that you know
magic open you need to put in there to
make it fall out you're just gonna break
your fingers off right
tee results by comparison okay
tears I'll just kind of like the big
gear when you first learn tear results
to do identities in that country you may
have noticed and iteration mighty
results are the same
sometimes it makes the question longer
like dramatically longer you got all
these lines and lines of algebra ah
but even though there's lots and lots of
lines we're very good at algebra we're
really really good now algebra and we
don't need to see magical things to do
algebra we just cancel things out and
move things around
we're very competent with that okay so
let me show you how to do this by tier
results instead rule that off
let's set the scene okay now this is the
way we this is a standard way that we
define T results right you start from
here and then out of that you get a
series of other results right you get
sine cos and ten in terms of T let's
remember what they are
let's do tan theta first because it's
the most common sense one you use double
angle you get two T on one minus T
squared good okay from there you can
also probably see you know this is sine
on clothes right so this represents a
sign in this record you've got sine
theta and you close theta so the sine is
going to be the two T and cos it's going
to be the one minus T squared put
something on it up right good okay
now there's one more piece that we
didn't need to worry about before but we
will need to if we're going to use this
for integration okay the idea is that we
are substituting one variable in this
case it was an X right now I'm talking
in terms of heaters but doesn't matter
I'm substituting one variable for
another okay now in differentiation
integration if you're changing variables
you can't just decide you want to change
it you have to account for it right use
chain rule you think about the
derivatives so what I'm going to do is
start with this and I want to know what
the derivative this is so that I can use
that integration later okay
so being that T is the subject there
what do you there am I going to get out
of this just by default is defeat on top
or is DT on the ontology
it is own table right so UT on the feed
on I'm differentiating with respect to
theta well I get 1/2
SEC squared be on to that all right
yeah that looks familiar okay now that's
okay that's true but I don't want to
only get rid of theaters right the whole
point of doing this is so that I can
change variable right so how can I get
this back in terms of some of the tees
that I've got what identity can probably
help us yup
IRA obviously I can go straight from the
Pythagorean Danny WITSEC squared
cannae what's the SEC squared even cute
it's tan squared plus one isn't it
square plus one is that all right but
that's just T that's that's just T so
I've got one plus t-squared on to right
that's the key on D theta but I actually
want to get rid of them I want to get
rid of theatres I want to make that this
subject so I'm going to turn this over
defeat our new T is actually what I want
okay so that's two all okay great
now their other color there and there
these are all the pieces I need to now
tackle this question again but not rely
on seeing any magical trig identities
okay let's try it if I've got one on one
plus cos x DX okay I've got two x terms
here with the cause and the the variable
of integration I need to get rid of
buddy okay because not too hard to get
rid of right so I can say let by the way
just like with normal T results you
always have to introduce why you're why
you're changing variable all of a sudden
okay so just like if you're doing the
trig identities question and you want to
rephrase it in terms of T's you can do
this to say sir
so let n equal T equal that
so I want cause X that'll be this one
right there for cos x equals now I could
substitute that in but while I've got it
well it's got my attention
I might as well not just work out cause
X but one plus cos x right so I can add
one to this okay so one plus cos x if I
add one to this I'll add it to this side
I'm gonna have this fraction here so I
might as well put them on a comment
denominator all at once so I'm gonna get
1 plus t squared 1 minus T squared
tracking so far yep good T scans cancel
and you get to close it okay also all
I'll write down this you don't need to
prove it every time you'll start to get
familiar with it you can use it without
any proof okay so now this and I've got
this time to substitute okay this is not
1 plus cos x it's the reciprocal right
so therefore it's the integral of the
reciprocal of this 1 plus T squared on
yeah turn that upside down now here I
have a DX I need to get rid of sorry
keep on thinking here's you can see here
that if I want the DX right well then I
do is can't the DT over to the side you
see it so I've got 2 on 1 plus T squared
DT now I've changed variables sweet it
just so happens in this example
everything cancels out so you're getting
the integral of 1 okay well that's T
plus a constant isn't it cool but of
course you know T's are foreign to the
question we introduced them not the
question so we better put it back in
terms of X's
tada no magical trying to work out
identities it's just algebra
and that's the beauty of Tyrians now
have a look compare the work that have
took me or the amount of time it took me
to get this versus the amount of time it
took me to get this okay this is quicker
it's a small gear right but if you don't
see it you don't see it and you don't
get anywhere right whereas here you're
automatically no it's very logical what
you have to do you're like well I've got
these pieces I'll just do them step by
step and then you suffer math and it's a
trivial integral really okay so that's
why you use intuition by T results